[Music]
please welcome Kanye West Kanye West
kept it super real on Thursdays Jimmy
Kimmel Live I know you guys wanted to
clap but everything I'm gonna say is
gonna be amazing the rapper talked about
a variety of topics from his personal
life to politics including this question
which left Kanye speechless when I see
people just even like go at the
president it's like why not try love you
so famously and so powerfully said
George Bush doesn't care about black
people it makes me wonder what makes you
think that Donald Trump does or any
people at all why don't we take a break
we'll come back a poignant moment
Kanye opened up about his own mental
health I think it's important for us to
have conversations about you know open
conversations about mental health I
think it's good that when I had my first
complete blackout at age five my mom
didn't fully medicate me because I might
have never been yay the father of three
also got sentimental telling a sweet
story about a bonding experience with
his five-year-old daughter Lord
my daughter went to a fashion camp for
five days a couple weeks ago and I
visited her visited her and we put
together we put the thread through the
sewing machine and it really brought me
to tears to think about the 15 years
that I've been working on apparel and my
daughter asked me daddy do you have a
sewing machine sewing machine like this
at your office and I brought her to my
office and she did a bunch of sketches
you